all right Lords a game we've got net
iron law podcast with the legendary the
airy the messenger Best Debut indie is
back we saw them last year 2017 how you
doing sir under great are you a real
festive tropical mood right now
absolutely yeah coming off the high of
winning that award how does it feel that
the game was to be celebrated when you
were in this area and you debuted this
game and this crazy ambition of the
messengers it was crazy man you know
because especially hitting that retro
nerve right it feels like it's been done
over and over and so how do you stand
out with it right so we took a few
creative risks and that all worked out
man so we're super stoked to be here
absolutely now what do we have here this
is new content DLC break it down for us
so it's called a picnic panic it's a
free DLC that we're doing as a thank-you
note you know to arrow to encourage the
game and so you know in the main game
it's like this big curse that's been the
hundreds of thousands of years and then
you have the breaking in so instead of
doing two like oh but two days later
it's back and you somehow bring it again
in two hours well we decided to branch
it off completely and do like more of we
think of it as kind of a Christmas
special you know it's like the lower
stakes lighthearted okay okay you know
just to send off you know like the
investiture deserves a vacation is the
best okay so like message your own
vacation is the Bible going oh yeah oh
yeah okay so there's terror in the
tropics you know okay so the messenger
has to go rescue some helpless creatures
that were taken hostage by an evil demon
okay but it's on tropical Phuket Island
so the first level
[Music]
here is basically that you will be
surfing to get to that tropical island
while we going or dawei tropical win it
totally okay binge on a surfboard I love
it let's go
she told me three vibes chugging it up
so basically what we do so the first
level is the surface that's how we get
there we go all the way back we back
baby we back
all right so that's no the first demo
now he's just going through the tutorial
so basically you'll learn hard to search
he'll be dodging rocks and all of that
all people who play the demo of mention
Battletoads which we might confess to
inspiration you don't like the TMNT on
discern no doubt so it's like Tuggle
Wade's okay so we go from lane to Lane
yeah and we got our obstacles were a
little bit of platforming with the jumps
and stuff like that right yeah
you have a boost get aggressive so
whenever there's debris like that you
can kind of like eat up them with your
moves and so you're doing like change
lanes nice and the idea is that you're
trying to maintain your boost by like
feeding it if that makes sense
I love the change of pace I think you
nailed it which is like light-hearted
coming off the seriousness of the
messenger story and just having some fun
really unique DLC right and so so this
is the first level to get to the island
and then after that you know it's I
won't spoil too much but you know it's
like would you'd expect like the beach
yes jungle who do magic volcano
okay you'll be finding a big totem you
know that's causing their tropical storm
and things like that so let me ask you
Allah during this section is our good
friend who we have to all live - is he
back is he stealing
yes it's grubbles stealing coins right
now if we mess up if corporal is always
there to save your life take your back
you know absolutely love the cow
hilarious mechanic and I don't think you
guys get enough credit for the humor you
infused in the game like just by going
to the store shops talk to them and he's
like hey why are you still here should
you be going out on the mission hey it's
just so many funny little nuances what
was the inspiration by all the humor in
the game well so the main I mean I was a
big fan of the LucasArts adventure games
you know and then what they had in their
writing you know and so that's kind of
like the otic dollars are often
unrecognized reference because Ninja
Gaiden is an obvious one you know send
for the other night and I'll have so
little Metro ed you know but yeah when
it comes to the writing you know it's
just this idea that you're playing a
game you should be having a good time
you know and hopefully your homework is
already done and I'm just like oh really
exactly rules are like welcome you in
there you know and just a setting that
stuff stressful yes I agree now as far
as levels how far as length what are we
looking at as far as length of a time
with this specific dlc that free right
well so it's a bit harder than the main
game so length will depend on skill
level
but basically we have three full levels
okay
including the serf and there's a fourth
one at the end that's just like an end
section with the big boss find our
worlds final but yeah basically after
the serf level you get to full-blown I
know messenger good message of levels
yeah platforming all that good stuff
using that cloud step job Oh back to
eight and sixteen again nice okay and
what about any on any new mechanics as
far as arm skills that he can learn
right so the character we like where the
character was and since we have you know
a New Game+ if we added skills it won't
be sort of fighting to the earlier
levels but it don't make sense so all
the new stone that we have is part of
the levels themselves instead of instead
of your character gotcha so you'll be
interacting with you enemies you'll be
interacting with you cabling new enemies
so basically we we we risk in that for
them to be tropical all the enemies like
there's not a single enemy from the the
picnic medic that you see in the main
game oh nice so we're really going what
do you think enemy types are variants of
like no behaviors and things like that
they're made to be a little bit harder
but they're also redesigned vision eyes
and anything now again another thing
that's really noticeable about your game
has been those iconic boss fights so do
we do at least we get at least one or
two maybe snuffed in this trouble what
do you mean if there's at least one or
two bosses yeah oh there's three bosses
oh great okay okay so yeah we have three
bosses on the first on the circle he'll
fight the big octopus at the air
and then there's two other bosses bocce
players love love the bosses man love
the fun little mechanics alright do we
are hype for this thing it's good to see
the growth it's good to see this thing
being somewhat it embraced by the
community and Bob Laura Cognito the
ninja guy so it's a ninja game I'm in
already but it's really good to see man
and this is out now this is where we are
so we're looking at June as a window we
don't have like a specific day because
you know it's just a free update that
we're giving out absolutely so it's not
like we're on schedule with pre-orders
or whatever so it's just like you know
sort of ready when it's ready nice right
it's right for the summer time y'all Joe
the messenger is back we got MJ the boss
on game play having a good time fighting
some octopus look like right now going
on let's see if you can get do this
before we get out of here Al's back at
him this is so cool they're so fun we
got the low parallax scrolling going on
bringing back 8-bit and 16-bit
sensibilities man it's so you know also
speaking to the music all the tracks are
brand new for this you know three levels
means tree level tracks and three bosses
means tree new bus tracks one of the
things I don't think you guys get enough
credit is the music oh yeah I'll be
knocking I don't like Lorca I'll knock
to those beats man it's a cool name
who's your guy behind the music again he
goes by rainbow dragon eyes his real
name is Erik he's with us here
and yeah he's our main guy like I mean
like composing music doing sound design
all the sound effects 100% it's all him
it was not furtive main game it's like
that with the deal says well it's a
little brother
I'm fixing things that are broken you
know guys you know mom man the messenger
back at PAX in celebratory fashion
one man theory another winner always a
pleasure to see him always great to
support indie devs and to see their
dream come to life and when I saw his
name called on that stage I was proud
man a proud brother in law podcast the
message to pick it up June 3 DLC three
tropical okay what suppose could go
wrong then come on